here's bianca hey good morning everybody
getting you out the door into
wherever you got to go as quickly as
possible right here it's now
6 18 but of course hopefully get your
location by 7 o'clock and on time
we're going to get to this situation
right here in the charleston curve in
just a moment
but taking a look at the 15 right here
at russell there was
an incident that has since been cleared
right there at 15 and russell
again smooth sailing in both directions
even though there is more traffic and
friends out there
sharing the road with you this is a
situation that is causing major delays
on the east part of our valley you can
see this is the
fifth 5 15 95 southbound at charleston
it was a multi-vehicle car crash here
as traffic now being able to get through
it for a moment it was at a standstill
they weren't letting anybody get by
but as you can see kind of you know
emergency vehicles on both sides because
there are multiple cars involved
you're still able to get through as far
as the drive times taking a look here
spaghetti bowl to the charleston again
you can see 16 minutes
about 20 minutes ago is that 10 minutes
so again be patient if you are going to
be in that area but if you're going in
the opposite direction of course
you're smooth sailing northbound and
then for our friends in the south part
of our valley we didn't forget about you
but you have no issues from the durango
to the 15
you're going to get there on time john
all right